شكرا لزميله نادين خماش مساء الخير
مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في التغطيه
المستمره للاوضاع في السودان ففي اليوم
التاسع من الاشتباكات استمرت المواجهات
رغم الهدنه المعلنه وتبادل الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع الاتهامات بمهاجمه قافله من
الرعايه الفرنسيه ياتي ذلك فيما تعهدت
الخارجيه الفرنسيه باغلاق سفرتها في
الخرطوم مع انتهاء عمليات الاجلاء خلال
ساعات ورغم استمرار الدعوات الدوليه
للتهدئه ووقف دائم لاطلاق النار تركزت
الاشتباكات في العاصمه الخرطوم وام درمان
وبحري فيما رصد مراسل العربيه تحليقا
للطيران الحربي في مدن سودانيه عده اما
فيما يخص التطورات الميدانيه فتتواصل
الاشتباكات في العاصمه الخرطوم بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع حيث شهدت بعض احياء
بحري وام درمان والخرطوم تحليقا للطيران
الحربي بحسب شهود عيان جهه اخرى تهمت قوات
الدعم السريع طيران الجيش بقصف مواقعها في
منطقه كافوري بالخرطوم بحري فيما تواصل
انقطاع الخدمه خدمه المياه في مدينه بحر
وعدد من احياء ولايه الخرطوم هذا ومن
المقرر ان تنتهي مساء اليوم هدنه كان قد
وافق عليها الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
بينما تواصلت ايضا حركه نزوح من الخرطوم
الى الولايات السودانيه الاخرى
هذا والتقطت كاميرا العربيه مشاهد للوضع
الانساني من داخل المستشفى الدولي في
السودان وهو المستشفى الوحيد الذي يعمل في
مدينه بحري ويعاني عجزا في الكوادر الطبيه
واصابات عديده بحسب احد الاطباء المتطوعين
هناك
ضرباني الطلقه تحت الحوض وعملنا عمليه
كبيره في المستشفى الدولي ماشي بكل
الكوادر الطبيه الجديده من المستشفى
الدولي لانه في عينيا
اكبر من
في حاله تانيه
نذكر بهذه الاخبار العاجله اسفل الشاشه
جوزيف بوريل يقول ان حمايه المدنيين في
السودان
اولويه جوزيف بول ايضا قال بانه اتفق مع
وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان على العمل لدفع السودانيين على وقف
اطلاق النار اذا جوزيف بوريل يقول بانه
اتفق مع وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان على العمل لدفع السودانيين
على وقف اطلاق النار اضاف ايضا بان حمايه
المدنيين في السودان اولويه هذا ابرز ما
جاء في تصريحات الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل والذي ذكر بانه اتفق
مع وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل ابن
فرحان على العمل لدفع السودانيين على وقف
اطلاق النار وكذلك حمايه التاكيد على
اهميه حمايه المدنيين في السودان وبانه
اولويه في هذه المرحله اذا ومع استمرار
خرق الهدنه تبادل الطرفان الاتهامات بشان
الاعتداء على البعثات الدبلوماسيه بينما
تستمر عمليه الاجلاء للرعايه الاجانب حيث
تام الجيش السوداني قوه الدعم السريع
بارتكاب انتهاكات ضد بعثه دبلوماسيه ليله
امس وذكر الجيش السوداني في بيان ان عناصر
من الدعم السريع اعتدت على السفير
الماليزي والبعثه القطريه المتجهه الى
بورسودان
كما تعرض موكب السفاره الفرنسيه لاطلاق
النار ما ادى الى عودتهم وتعطيل عمليه
الاجلاء في المقابل ايضا قالت قوه الدعم
السريع في بيان ان طائرات الجيش هي التي
استهدفت موكب السفاره الفرنسيه وشددت
الدعم السريع على التزامها بالهدنه وتسير
حركه الرعايه الاجانب لمنطقه الاجلال
من جانبه تاما المستشار الاول لقائد قوات
الدعم السريعه فارس النور في مقابله مع
العربيه اتهم عناصر قال انها مندسسه
بتنفيذ الاعتداءات على البعثات
الدبلوماسيه
هنالك الان
كتيبه كامله متفرغه من الطرف الاخر ترتدي
زي الدعم السريع لكي تدق السينما بين
الدعم السريع والمجتمع الدولي هم انضربوا
الرصاص على
السفاره الامريكيه هم اعتدوا على
سفير الاتحاد الاوروبي
ونفى النور للعربيه رغبه الدعم السريع
كبديل عن الجيش وقال ان قوات الدعم السريع
مستعده للاندماج في الجيش بعد تطهيره من
عصابات سيطرت عليه وفق تعبيره
وهنا في نقطه مهمه
نحن حتى
يعني احنا ما صالحين نفسنا بديل للجيش
السوداني
نحن دايرين نطهر الجيش السوداني من
العصابه التي
وبعد ذلك الجيش السوداني هو الاساس لكي
نكون جيش قومي نحن سوف نندمج في الجيش
السوداني لكي نكون جيش رومي يحمي الدستور
يحمل البلاد من الاعداء الخارجيين
هذا هدفنا نحن لسنا بديلين للجيش
وينضموا الينا من القاهره الكاتب الصحفي
السوداني حمور زياده سيد حمور مرحبا بك
معي في هذه النشره
اليوم التاسع من الاشتباكات لا زال الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع يتبادلان الاتهامات
فيما يعني يخص الهجوم على البعثات
الدبلوماسيه قبل ان تغادر الخرطوم الى اي
مدى المشهد السوداني يزداد تعقيدا برايك
العسكري يتحدث
هذه الاتهامات المتبادله امر طبيعي كل
واحد يحاول ان يتنصل منا المسؤوليه
المباشره من الاعتداء على البعثات
الدبلوماسيه انا في تقديري انه يعني
الاغلب ان هذه الاعتداءات وقعت من قوات
الدعم السريع يعني هذه القوات
الجيش به تفلتات ايضا لكن الاكبر اكيد
ستكون في قوات مثل قوات الدعم السريع خاصه
اذا صدقت التقارير التي تقول ان القياده
لقياده قوات الدعم السريع لم تعد تستطيع
التواصل مع اغلب قواعدها فبالتالي هم
يتحركون بشكل عشوائي وفردي
فقد يكون هم من اعتدوا على هذه المواكب
والسيارات الاجلاء لكن في ذات الوقت علينا
لا ننسى احتماليات اخرى مثل ان الجيش
يمتلك ازياء الدعم السريع الدعم السريع
يمتلك ازياء الجيش وهناك ايضا هيئه
العمليات التابعه لجهاز الامن والمخابرات
السابقه المحلوله التي اغلب كوادرها من
الحركه الاسلاميه هذه تمتلك ازياء الجيش
والشرطه والدعم السريع وكل الوحدات
العسكريه في السودان وكانوا يتحركون بهذا
الشكل فيعني الاحتمالات هنا مفتوحه انه
ربما هناك اعتداءات من الطرفين المتقاتلين
ربما هناك من يريد ان يزيد الامور اشتعالا
انا لا اميل الى نظريات المؤامره لذلك
اعتقد الى حد كبير انه قد يكون الدعم
السريع هو وقد مدهان منهاجا لكن تظل
الخيارات مفتوحه وتظل الاحتمالات موجوده
على الطاوله طيب السؤال ماذا بعد اجلاء
الرعايه سيد حمور هل هناك نذر بمشوار طويل
من الحرب والخراب في السودان برايك
اعتقد ان هذا واضح يعني عمليه الاجلاء هذه
التي تتم في اليوم الثامن والتاسع هذا
اولا يعني نحن قضينا اكثر من اسبوع في هذه
الحرب المفتوحه والعمليات العسكريه وكل
طرف يرفض تماما التنازل تصريحات قائد
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو حميدتي
الاخيره ان الاشتباكات لن تقف الا
باستسلام البرهان وعصابته او تسليم انفسهم
هذا يعني انها يعني عمليه ستستمر حتى
النهايه حتى يقطع احد القائدين راس الاخر
ولا يهمهما من يمكن ان يموت في المنتصف
هذا طبعا في الحقيقه ياتي على عكس
التصريحات قائد الجيش التي اطلقها امس في
اتصال مع العربيه انه يرى هذه الحرب عبثيه
وانها حرب لا فائده منها لكن هو ايضا يعني
اشتراطاته لوقف الحرب ليس فقط وقف اطلاق
النار ولكن انما ان تخرج قوات الدعم
السريع من المدن وهذا طلب بقدر ما هو فعلا
يحقق الامان الناس لكن ان يطلبه الا واحد
من الجانبين المتصارعين وهذا يعني ببساطه
انه يطلب من الجانب الاخر ان يستسلم فكلا
الجانبين يرفعان سقف مطالبهم ما يريدان من
الجانب الاخر ان يضع سلاحه ويسلم نفسه له
وهذا امر لن يقود الا الى تعقد الاوضاع
بالتالي ان عمليه اجراء الرعايه
والموظفي السفارات تعني ان هذه الدول
وتقديراتها الاستخباراتيه وتقديرات الموقف
التي قاموا بها ان الامور ذاهبه الى
الاسوا خاصه انه مع هذه العمليات العسكريه
بدا الان حاله انفلات امني هناك نقص كبير
جدا في المواد الغذائيه حصل الهجوم على
بعض الشركات والمخازن اعتقد انه منازل
السفارات ومنازل اعضاء البعثات
الدبلوماسيه قد تكون هدف يعني قد يظن
الناس ان بها اموال ان بها مواد غذائيه
باعتبار ان يعني الشائع في الشارع
السوداني دائما ان هناك حياه رفاهيه تدور
خلف اسوار منازل السفراء فبالتالي قد في
خطر كبير خاصه اذا تواصلت الحرب وتصاعدت
الى ما لا يحمد عقبه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل قال قبل قليل بانه
تواصل مع وزير الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن
فرحان
محاوله ان يدفع السودانيين الى وقف لاطلاق
النار او على الاقل لتمديد هذه الهدنه ما
هي
افاق هذا الطلب هل تعتقد بانه من الممكن
ان يكون الوسيط السعودي في هذه الازمه
قادرا على وقف اطلاق النار اقناع كل
الاطراف
الحقيقه الامكان يمكن ان اضع بعض العول
قليلا على هذه التصريحات لكن اليوم مع
دخول اليوم التاسع يبدو لي ان المجتمع
الدولي والاقليمي لا يريد ان يضغط بقوه
وبحسم من اجل وقف اطلاق النار هو يمشي
بخطوات بطيئه عسى ان ياتيه الحل من السماء
ويقضي احد الطرفين على الاخر او ينهكاه
فيقوما بوقف اطلاق النار نحن في اليوم
التاسع لهذه العمليات مع حالات نزوح كبيره
مع تضرر المدنيين مئات القتلى الاف الجرحى
حتى هذه اللحظه مجلس الامنيه تحدث عن
احتماليه تحديد موعد لعقد جلسه لمناقشه ما
يجري
وكل التصريحات نعم التصريحات الدوليه كلها
سواء من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من
رئيسها جو بايدن او من الاتحاد الاوروبي
او غيرها هي كلها تامل وتتمنى وتطالب بشكل
يعني ليس فيه اي
احساس بالضغط العالي على
العيدين انا اعتقد انه هناك دول اقليميه
وهناك دول في في العالم اذا كانت جاده في
محاوله وقف اطلاق النار فانها تستطيع ان
تضغط على القائدين بسبب ان بينهم تحالفات
وان لديهم مصالح مشتركه لكنها واضح انه
هناك تريد الامور الى هذه النقطه تحديدا
والتوسع ايضا فيها لكن نتوقف مع بعض
الاخبار قليلا في الشان السعودي او عفوا
في شان السوداني السعودي ايضا حيث بحث
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل الجهود
المبذوله لوقف التصعيد العسكري بين
الاطراف المتنازعه وانهاء العنف في
السودان بالاضافه الى توفير الحمايه
اللازمه للمدنيين السودانيين والمقيمين
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي كشف عن توافق سعودي اوروبي على
العمل الجماعي من اجل وقف اطلاق النار في
السودان
ذكر قائد قوات الدعم السريع في السودان
محمد حمدان دقلو انه اكد لمنسق السياده
السياسات الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
التزامه قواته المطلق بالهدنه الانسانيه
المعلنه مضيفا ان قواته مستعده لتقديم ما
يلزم من تسهيلات تساعد المواطنين
والجاليات الاجنبيه على المرور الى اماكن
امنه
من جانبها اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان عن
ارتفاع عدد ضحايا الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع الى 264 قتيلا من
المدنيين
و1543 جريحا واوضحت اللجنه في بيان ان
هناك الكثير من الاصابات والوفيات غير
مشموله في هذا الحصر حيث لم تتمكن من
الوصول الى المستشفيات لصعوبه التنقل
والوضع الامني في البلاد
هذا وافاد موقع رصد للانترنت ان السوداني
يعاني انقطاعا شبه كامل لخدمه الانترنت مع
دخوله المعارك بين الجيش السوداني وبين
قوات الدعم السريع اسبوعها الثاني وقالت
منظمه نتفلوكس ومقرها لندن قالت ان بيانات
الشبكه تظهر انهيارا شبه كامل للاتصال
بالانترنت حيث تبلغ نسبه الاتصال حاليا 2%
مقارنه بالمستويات العاديه
نشر الجيش السوداني مقطعا لنائب رئيس
الاركان السودانيه الفريق عباس الدروتي
بين الجنود يلقي عليهم التحيه ويهنئهم
بعيد الفطر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر الله اكبر كل عام وانتم بخير ان
شاء الله
[موسيقى]
مره اخرى الى ضيفي من القاهره الكاتب
الصحفي حمر زياره سيد حمور كنا نتحدث قبل
قليل وقلت بان هناك دولا وجهات يمكنها
الرعايه اي اتفاق او وساطه لايقاف اطلاق
النار في السودان ولو حتى بشكل
مؤقت من هي الجهه القادره على هذا الامر
برايك
بدون يعني الدخول في تفاصيل تحديد اسماء
دول لكن يعني القوات المسلحه لديها شركات
في الاقليم لديها شركات دوليه لديها مصالح
مشتركه مع عدد من الدول ايضا الدعم السريع
لديه امتدادات اقليميه سواء في الوطن
العربي او في افريقيا وايضا له ارتباطات
دوليه اعتقد ان هذه العلاقات التي استمرت
منذ 2019 حتى هذه اليوم هذه الدول وهذه
الكائنات الخارجيه قادره على ان يعني تضغط
على حلفائها في الداخل للوصول مبدئيا الى
عمليه وطف وقف اطلاق نار نحن لا نستطيع
الان نتحدث عن عمليه سياسيه ولا عن تسليم
سلطه ولا عن حل نهائي نحن نريد في البدايه
وقف اطلاق نار لان حاله المدنيين اصبح سيء
جدا الخدمات كلها انهارت كما تفضلتم في
تقاريركم لا يمكن ان نستمر هذا الوضع ايام
او اسابيع قادمه والا ستكون هناك كارثه
انسانيه عظيمه جدا في السودان لذلك الحل
الاول هو وقف اطلاق النار بشكل مباشر
وتمكين المدنيين اما من النزوح الامنه او
من الحصول على الخدمات داخل الخط الطرفين
هذه
الازمه يرفضون تدويل الوساطه بينهما في
هذه الازمه اليوم فبالتالي الا يمكن توقع
اختراق لهذه المساله
هما يعني اليوم الاول يقولان انهما يرفضات
تدوين لكن انا اعتقد انه هذه يعني تصريحات
استهلاكيه رايناها ايضا ايام العمليه
السياسيه كان قائد الجيش يخرج ليهدد
السفراء الاجانب ويخرج ليهدد مبعوث الامين
العام المبعوث الخاص للامين العامل الامم
المتحده السيد فوركلبيرتس ثم ينخرط معهم
في اجتماعات لمناقشه العمليه السياسيه
يعني هذه تصريحات من اجل الاستهلاك ومن
اجل وضع متاريس امام اي اتفاقات يمكن ان
ان تحدث او ضغوط قويه لكن في النهايه انا
اعتقد انهم يخضعون للضغوط الطرفين او
الطرفان يعني لا يستطيعان مقاومه الضغوط
الدوليه خاصه الضغوط التي تاتي من
حلفائهما
طيب
السؤال ايضا كذلك اليوم كان هناك حديث عن
اطلاق
السجناء من سجن الهدى تحديدا
الازمه لا يمكن ان تتفاقم بعد اطلاق سراح
هؤلاء المساجين او حتى من يوصفون بانهم
مجرمين لاي مدرسه يتفاقم الوضع في السودان
اكثر فاكثر بعد اطلاقي سراحهم من هذه
السجون
هو تم الاعتداء على سجنين سجن الهدى وسجن
صوبه تقريبا وتم اطلاق السجناء بهم
يعني من ناحيه انسانيه طبعا يعني قد يكون
من الافضل لهؤلاء السجناء ان لا يكونوا
اسرى في في
مرحله عمليات كهذه لا يوجد احد يوفر لهم
الطعام والشراب وغيرها لكن من ناحيه اخرى
هذا اكيد مساله خطره جدا ان تطلق بصراحه
المئات والالاف من المدانين في جرائم عنف
في ظروف مثل هذه في المدينه هذا امر يعقد
الوضع وللاسف هو يذكرنا انه في بعض الدول
يعني قامت السلطات باطلاق سراح ارهابيين
محتجزين من اجل ان يحملوا السلاح حتى يكون
هذا مبرر للسلطه الحاكمه كي تقوم بعمليات
عنف ضد المحتجين فالاحتمالات هنا مفتوحه
على سبب استخدام هؤلاء المساجين هل هو
لاثاره الرعب في المدينه وشغل القوات
النظاميه عن مواجهه الدعم السريع ام
لاستخدامهم في القتال يعني ربما شخص يخرج
من السجن فيجد من يعرض عليه وظيفه مقاتل
قد يقبل هذه المساله وبالتاكيد هناك من لم
يقبله هناك ما خرجوا في الاعلام وصرحوا
انهم خائفون على حياتهم ويفضلون العوده
الى السجن حتى لا يتعرضوا لمطاردات لاحقه
او يتعرضون
هل سيتم استخدامهم للقتال الى جانب قوات
الدعم السريع والتي تتهم بانها هي من
اطلقت سراح هؤلاء المساجين ام سيتم
استخدامهم لاشغال القوات النظاميه كما
ذكرت قبل قليل اي السيناريو وهين اقرب الى
يمكن
لا تعارض بين السيناريوهين يعني لا يمكن
استخدام جميع السجناء لا اعتقد ان كلهم
ايضا سيقبلون منهم بالتاكيد من سيقبل ان
يحمل السلاح وينقرض مع القوات الدعم
السريع ويقاتل معها منهم من سيرفض ويخرج
يعني يحاول اكتساب رزقه من الشارع عبر
الاعتداءات وبالتاكيد ايضا منهم مجموعات
لن تقبل بهذه المساله ربما تبقى في
منازلها ربما تحاول العوده الى السجون هذا
ايضا حدث في بعض الاماكن في العالم في وقت
الحروب عندما كانت تنهار اسوار السجن
باعتداءات عشوائيه كان احيانا المساجين
يقومون ببناء السور ويبقون داخل السجون
طيب
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من القاهره الكاتبه
الصحفيه السودانيه حمور زياد
ومع تصاعد الاضطرابات في السودان اعلنت
الخارجيه المصريه اصابه احد اعضاء السفاره
في الخرطوم بطلق النار واكدت ان هذا
الحادث يؤكد مره اخرى على ضروره توخي اقصى
درجات الحذر حفاظا على سلامه المواطنين
والدبلوماسيين ودعت الخارجيه المصريه
المواطنين المصريين الموجودين خارج
الخرطوم الى التوجه الى مدينتي حلفا
وبورسودان تمهيدا لاجلائهم هذا وقالت
مصادر العربيه ان مصر ستمنح تاشيره دخول
للرعايه الاجانب القادمين من السودان
وعلى صعيدي عمليات الاجراء المستمره في
السودان على نطاق خارجيه الفرنسيه عن بدء
عمليه اجراء سريعه لمواطنيها ولطاقمها
الدبلوماسي بعد ان دخلت المعارك العنيفه
اسبوعها الثاني ولفتت الخارجيه الفرنسيه
الى ان العمليه ستشمل ايضا مواطنين
اوروبيين واخرين يتبعون دولا حليفه مؤكده
انها حصلت على ضمانات من طرفي الصراع في
السودان لتامين عمليه الاجلاء
هذا وتتواصل عمليه اجراء الرعايه الاجانب
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم نحو بورتسودان بسبب
تدهور الوضع الامني الناتج عن الصراع
الحاصل بين المكونين العسكريين
[موسيقى]
من جانبها علقه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه نشاطها في السودان واجلت راعيها
من الخرطوم وقال وزير خارجيه الامريكي
انتوني بلينكن ان بلاده علقت بصفه مؤقته
العمليات في السفارات ابو الخرطوم بسبب
تزايد المخاطر الامنيه واجلت جميع
الموظفين الامريكيين وعائلاتهم بامان
رصدت كاميرا العربيه ازمه الخبز التي بدات
في الظهور في الخرطوم حيث احتشدت الطوابير
امام الافران
نذكر مشاهدينا بان العربيه ستعرض لكم بعد
قليل مقابله اجرتها مع الرئيس الاوكراني
اذا الرئيس الاوكراني
سيتحدث الى قناه العربيه بعد قليل
منتصف هذه الساعه اذا مشاهدينا بالحديث
وبالعوده الى الشان السوداني تهدد ازمه
المياه حياه السودانيين بعدما شهدت البلاد
انقطاعا تاما للمياه الصالحه للشرب اثر
استهداف المعارك محطات المياه في العاصمه
ما يجتمع عليه هؤلاء
من ماء بئر بعد طول عناء ازمه انقطاع
المياه في السودان تدفع هؤلاء الى الامر
مياه عكره باتت بفعل الحرب صالحه للشرب
فلا خيار اخر
يخاطر مدنيون في سبيل البحث عن الماء تشهد
المنطقه هنا وسط الخرطوم معارك محتدمه لم
يترك الرصاص شيئا الا وعليه اثره
رجع رجع جنب البير وقع جنبك اخيرا يعود
بعضهم محملين بما لا يروي ولا يغني من عطش
اما على الضفه هنا نهر على سعته يلجاون
اليه يحتفظون بماء النهر حيله قد تعينهم
لايام بعد معارك سببت نقصا في المياه
الصالحه للشرب
دي انقطعت تماما الظهر
شحوا المياه يضرب العاصمه الخرطومه بعد
معارك بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع
استهدفت محطات المياه
محطات يصعب الوصول لها واصلاحها لاستمرار
الصراع في محيطها
فيما طالبت منظمه الصحه بوقف فوري لاطلاق
النار خوفا من تداعيات انسانيه قد تكون
الاسوا في تاريخ السودان غيداء السالم
العربيه
[موسيقى]
الان الى ابرز الاخبار الدوليه الاخرى حيث
اعلنت وزيره الداخليه الالمانيه توصل
الحكومه والنقابات العماليه الى اتفاق
بشان رواتب اكثر من مليونين ونصف المليون
موظف القطاع العام اوضحت الوزيره في بيان
ان كل عامل سيتلقى ما مجموعه 3000 يورو
على شكل اقساط حتى فبراير العام المقبل
للمساعده في التعويض عن التضخم
احتج نائب وزير الخارجيه الصيني سونوي
دونج على تصريحات رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه
بشان تايوان حيث ذكر نائب وزير الخارجيه
الصيني لسفير كوريا الجنوبيه ان التصريحات
الرئيس الكوري الجنوبي غير مقبوله على
الاطلاق مضيفا ان الرئيس الكوري الجنوبي
لم يشير الى مبدا صين واحده لكنه ساوى بين
قضيه تايوان وقضيه شبه الجزيره الكوريه في
اشاره منه الى قضيه شبه الجزيره الكوريه
وقضيه تايوان والتي تختلفان تماما في
طبيعتهما
قال مسؤولون محليون ان ما لا يقل عن خمسه
صواريخ روسيه اصابت مدينه خاركف شرق
اوكرانيا والمناطق المحيطه بها حيث كتب
حاكم المنطقه على تطبيق تيليجرام من
صاروخا اصاب منزلا في احدى القرى جنوب
المدينه بينما تسبب صاروخ اخر في اندلاع
حريق كبير في المدينه نفسها والحق بعض
الاضرار في مباني مدنيه هذا وتطلق روسيا
منذ اشهر طائرات مسيره وصواريخ ضد مجموعه
متنوعه من الاهداف الاوكرانيه في محاوله
لتدمير البنيه التحتيه الحيويه
تغطيتنا مستمره للنزاع في السودان لكن
نتوقف الان مع لقاء خاص اجرته العربيه مع
الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي ميرسي يازميل عادل
عيدان يلقاكم على راس لاكمال التغطيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات